[Música]
เฮ
Olá, meus amigos, minhas amigas. Sejam
muito bem-vindos a mais uma live. Temos
algumas perguntas para responder aqui.
Eu só preciso checar se eu tô com as
perguntas
atualizadas. Pode ser que tenha chegado
mais
perguntas. Eu acho que chegou sim.
Me deem só um instante
[Música]
aqui. Ah, o problema é que ele tá
misturando as perguntas
aqui. Eu acho que eu vou ter que
colocar individuais as respostas porque
senão
fica
confuso. É, realmente tá misturando. Ele
não coloca em
ordem que as perguntas
chegaram. Bem, vamos lá. Depois eu vejo
como é que eu vou resolver
isso. Boa noite, Maura. Boa noite Alice
Vogel, Ruberg, Eliane, Eloía, obrigado
por est acompanhando ao vivo. Bem, a
primeira pergunta que eu tenho
aqui é uma pergunta enorme, né? Deixa eu
achar ela aqui. Acho que não vai dar nem
para mostrar na tela, porque ela é muito
grande e é meio que tentativa de
consulta, né?
Mas vamos responder de uma maneira mais
genérica, porque aqui não é objetivo da
gente responder no sentido de que fosse
uma consulta, tá? Bem, eu vou ler, não
sei nem se eu vou ler a pergunta toda
porque ela é enorme,
tá? Estou com problema, não sei mais o
que fazer. por favor, me dê um caminho
para seguir o meu tratamento. Estou
perdido. Eu penso em melhorar a saúde e
ocorre ao contrário. Em vez de melhorar,
crio coisas que não existiam, estavam
missas e foram expostas ao tratamento.
Eu vou dar uma resposta para te
direcionar, mas entenda que isso não é
uma consulta informal, tá? Eu quero
ajudar da melhor forma sem criar algum
tipo de problema. Também não vou
identificar a pessoa que fez a pergunta.
Eu estava querendo melhorar minha
digestão, é lenta. Ele diz que tem
hipocloridria,
difícil. IP, por consequência, uma
disbiose
intestinal. I é uma sigla que eu não
entendi bem que sigla que é. Tenho
vários polimorfismos que favorecem esse
quadro. Aí eu não vou falar os
polimorfismos porque é tudo uma sopa de
letrinha.
transportadores de sódio, bicarbonato.
Então, comecei com uma estimulação vagal
para melhoria da produção de
áculoídrico, tomando 30 minutos antes
das refeições, um copo de
água com uma colher de chá de
bicarbonato. Por conta desse snip,
outras vezes estimulo com chá de
gengibre. E no alta da refeição, eu
estimulo
pâncreas com uma gota de óleo essencial
de hortelã pimenta embaixo da língua,
outra vez com titura marca digciana.
e mastigação
lenta. Resultado, ponto
positivo. As fees melhoraram a
consistência, dores e firmeza e se
acabaram os gases e não tem mais aquele
odor de putrefação. Ponto negativo, como
as fezes deixaram de ser pastosas e
agora grossas, causaram ou exibiram uma
fissura anal e agora sangra toda semana
que evacua. E também apareceu uma tosse
seca e às vezes com catarro. Já tive
tosse que duraram 6 meses para ficar
bom. Detalhe, não adianta tomar remédio
antitosse que não passa de forma alguma
essa tosse. Tenho exames de alfa
antistina abaixo dos valores de
referência, tanto no sangue como nas
feeses. Detalhe, vários marcadores das
feeses altos, como estamina, ácidos
orgânicos totais e baixa
digestibilidade, onde alfam antitina era
para ser alto e estava
baixo. O meu exame genético não analisou
snip sobre doenças pulmonares e
hepáticas. Por três vezes parei
estimulação e a tosse parou. E comecei a
estimulação e a tosse voltou. Para quem
tá escutando isso não dá, deve tá
entendendo nada, tá? Mas eu vou tentar
aqui responder da melhor forma para ver
se ajuda as outras pessoas que estão na
live. Também tenho suspeita de ter
polimorfismo gen serpina um. Não sei se
esse exame serve de algo. Já falei com o
senhor sobre a estimulação do alfum
antripsina. Eu fiz e não adiantou. Me
parece que essa proteína que eu fabrico
não cumpre suas funções porque está
dobrada. Não sei o que fazer para parar
a estimulação e voltar à disbiose, mas
vou proteger os meus pulmões e o fígado
e continuar com a estimulação. E acho
uma maneira de proteger os meus pulmões
e
fígado. Tá? Eh, vou parar por aqui, né?
Bem, existe uma correlação entre a
estimulação vagal e o aparecimento da
tosse que você
comentou. Eh, os seus sintomas e
resultados, né, que vou aqui analisar
tudo item por item, mas eles sugerem que
é uma deficiência assim de 5 alfa,
desculpa, de alfa ou anticina.
E o fato dela tá baixa tanto no sangue
quanto nas feeses é preocupante, né? Mas
tem que ser investigado aí em consulta,
não numa live,
né? Vamos lá. Pois em condições
inflamatórias intestinais, esse
alfomantina
fecal, ou seja, em condições de
inflamação, deveria estar elevado.
OK? Esse polimorfismo que você comentou
tá associado à sensibilidade ao sal.
Isso que você disse que fez o exame
genético. E pode afetar o transporte de
sódio e bicarbonato dessa bomba aí, tá?
E alfa, uma antitripsina baixa, pode ter
correlação com a deficiência genética
que você comentou o serpina
um. Existe uma correlação temporal, né?
A tosse que você comentou aparece com a
estimulação e desaparece quando você
para.
Então, a deficiência da alfomantitina
pode causar dois problemas distintos,
né? E nos
pulmões, isso vai uma permitir uma
atividade descontrolada, uma enzima
chamada elaste. Isso pode causar dano
pulmonar e no fígado pode acumular essa
proteína nos hepatócitos, né? Essa
proteína mal
dobrada. Qual que é a estratégia que eu
te recomendo? Faça a investigação
genética do gene serpina um. Tá? Então,
marca uma consulta com o geneticista e
pede esse
exame. Eu sugiro que você suspenda
temporariamente o
bicarbonato, porque ele pode ser
excessivo pro seu
polimorfismo e também suspenda a
estimulação vagal que você tá fazendo,
tá? Quais seriam alternativas mais
seguras paraa digestão? suporte
enzimático usando enzimas
pancreáticas e o cloridado
betaína em doses menores e controladas e
mais
frequentes. E também pode usar pepsina.
Pode continuar usando o chá de gengibre.
Você pode utilizar tintura de genciana
para estimular o ácido clorídrico e a
mastigação lenta que você tá fazendo é
necessário manter. Enquanto você aguarda
a consulta e os resultados genéticos,
evite exposição a irritantes do pulmão.
monitore a função do fígado e considere
antioxidantes pro fígado, é o caso do
NAC e da
gluta bom você pensar em usar
probióticos e prebióticos, uma dieta
antiinflamatória e
fermentados. E pro tratamento da fissura
anal, você pode usar fibras solúveis
para amolecer as feeses, óleo de coco ou
vaselina líquida local, né, para
diminuir a irritação, banho de assento
com água morna.
e pode também pensar em suplementar com
magnésio. Espero ter ajudado, tá? Mas a
sua pergunta foi muito específica e
muito longa e eu já falei em momentos
anteriores que eu não tenho intenção
nenhuma de fazer consultas online aqui
no no grupo de apoiadores por questão de
ética e também por uma questão de não tá
indicando uma coisa errada baseada em
pouca informação, tá? Mas assim, eu
entendo o teu desespero, por isso que eu
quis te responder aqui, mas precisa
realmente ajudar uma consulta de
preferência com
geneticista. Próxima pergunta aqui.
Deixa eu ver se eu coloco na tela. Essa
não quis colocar porque era muito
grande. Vamos pra próxima
aqui. Tá aqui. Deixa eu aumentar o
tamanho da pergunta.
Homem de 28 anos, esquecendo muito,
compra no mercado, paga, esquece de
pegar as compras e só lembra quando é
avisado. Isso aconteceu umas três vezes
quando quando deixa a moto estacionada
com frequência, esquece o local que
deixou, fica procurando, mas achea
esquece o que falou. Desculpa, pessoal,
é porque não tem ponto de nenhum de de
interrogação, de exclamação, de vírgula,
aí tá difícil de ler maneira melhor,
né? Há pouco tempo ri sozinho fica no
mundo da lua, mas não perde a noção eh
da realidade. E quando uma pessoa chega,
se toca que está sendo visto e para, tem
ansiedade e com frequência balança as
mãos quando está andando na rua também.
Ti sozinho deve ser rir sozinho. O que
pode
ser? Gente, isso aqui também é uma
pergunta para tentar fazer diagnóstico,
tá? É, é, é o que eu explico para vocês.
Não façam perguntas assim, porque eu
posso com as informações inadequadas
fazer um diagnóstico errado, certo?
Isso pode ser um autismo, pode ser um
TDAH, pode, pode ser um transtorno de
ansiedade generalizada, pode. Então fica
difícil a gente ter certeza o que é, né?
Teria que passar por uma
avaliação completa, certo?
A risada sozinha e os comportamentos
repetitivos não necessariamente indicam
autismo, que uma ansiedade, por
exemplo, pode ser a causa dessa risada
em momentos
inoportunos, que é uma tentativa do
corpo de aliviar sensações de estresse e
ansiedade. E o balançar das mãos também
não necessariamente é uma é um autismo,
pode representar um comportamento
estereotipado relacionado ansiedade.
OK? Então são essas as opções que eu
colocaria
aqui pra próxima pergunta.
Deixa eu ver
aqui. É sobre o pé, mas tá fora de ordem
aqui. O pé ficasse para dores em geral
ou seria mais propaganda? Acho que eu
vou tirar as perguntas da tela, é
melhor, porque eu não quero identificar
as pessoas
aqui. Então vamos pra próxima pergunta
aqui. O pé eficaz para dores em geral
seria mais propaganda com base nas
evidências, tá? O que eu posso dizer
para vocês que o pé é assim, ele tem
eficácia real, ele não é apenas
propaganda, tá bom? Pel, pommitoí,
etanolamina. Tem muitas evidências e as
mais convincentes vem de várias
metaanálises que são independentes. Teve
uma de 2023 que analisou 11 estudos com
774 pacientes e nessa metanálise
descobriu-se que o PEA reduziu
significativamente os scores de dor, tá?
Então teve eh diferença
estatística eh bem significativa aqui
com P bem baixo aqui, que é o valor que
a gente usa para ver a diferença
estatística. Então teve 68% a mais de
controle da dor no pessoal que tava
usando
PEA. Uma metaanálise mais recente agora
desse ano incluiu 18 estudos, foram mais
pacientes, foram
1196 e confirmou redução significativa
da dor, tá? depois de 24 a 26 semanas de
tratamento. Então, PEA tem eficácia
comprovada para dor nocepitiva, dor
neuropática e dor
nociplástica. E o mecanismo de ação da
do pé é através do sistema
endocanabinoide. Ele se liga a nos
receptores CB1 e CB2. Então, ele cabe
muito bem também com o extrato de
cannabis.
Então, os estudos demonstraram que o PE
reduz a inflamação em nível celular,
especialmente nas células gliis, que são
a célula de suporte do sistema nervoso,
né, da dos neurônios. Ele ativa também
os canais iônicos dos receptores
vaniloides, que é o TRPV1 e
TRPA. E tem um perfil de segurança muito
bom.
tem algumas limitações, apesar de ser
muito promissor,
tá? Os estudos que foram analisados aí
nas
metanálises têm uma
heterogeneidade, então eles querem fazer
ainda mais estudos, tá? Mas eu tenho
convicção que o PE funciona bem, sim,
tá? Especialmente para dor crônica e dor
neuropática. Vamos pra próxima pergunta.
A suplementação de ferro na forma
líquida é mais eficiente que em cápsula.
Tem algum efeito no sistema de
funcionamento
intestinal? Não, não tem nada a ver se é
líquido ou se ser sólido. Isso não é o
ponto principal aqui do ferro ser
eficaz, tá?
A forma líquida não vai ser
necessariamente mais eficaz ou
eficiente. Tem um estudo com prematuros
que demonstrou que a fórmula fortificada
com ferro foi mais eficaz que gotas de
sulfato
ferroso e isso foi atribuído à ingestão
regular e fracionada do nutriente. Isso
não tem nada a ver com o tipo de se é
líquido ou é
sólido. E nós sabemos que a forma
líquida é mais apropriada para as
crianças, né, devido à
aceitabilidade. O que vai aumentar a
eficiência ou a eficácia do ferro é o
tipo químico, né, o ferro bisglicinato
quelado, que é uma das formas que eu
prefiro. Ele é cinco vezes mais
absorvido que o sulfato ferroso, por
exemplo. E o fracionamento da dose
também ajuda na absorção.
E temos que lembrar que a suplementação
com ferro pode causar problemas na
função intestinal independente da forma.
Então, pessoas que usam ferro podem ter
constipação, diarreia, irritação da
mucosea, independente se é líquido ou
não. E o ferro bisclicinato realmente
tem menos efeitos colaterais, dá menos
náusea, dá menos vômito, menos sensação
de plenitude, constipação,
diarreia.
Tá? Próxima pergunta. Quantos dias no
mês pode-se usar a progesterona
sublingual no período da
pós-menopausa? Tá? Tem vários esquemas
possíveis, tá?
O uso mais comum é o uso sequencial de
12 a 14 dias por mês, sendo
administrado nas últimas duas semanas de
cada ciclo. Então esse esquema é
utilizado quando a gente quer manter os
ciclos, né, fisiológicos, né, como se
fosse a menstruação normal, né, de
sangramento e
proteção endometrial. Tem o esquema do
uso contínuo, que é mais comum depois da
menopausa, né?
Porque a pergunta foi pós-menopausa, né?
Eu tava entendendo que era
pré-menopausa. Então, no pós-menopausa é
mais comum de usar contínuo todos os
dias do
mês, especialmente para mulheres que não
querem ter mais sangramento,
tá? E também tem um esquema de você usar
de 25 a 30 dias por mês com pausa de
poucos dias.
E na verdade eu não vejo muita vantagem
na forma, tudo bem que evita a primeira
passagem hepática, né? Mas nesse caso,
se você quer evitar a primeira passagem
hepática, usa transdérmico, né? ou se
você talvez não quer usar o transdêmico
por algum
motivo. Eh, mas se você usar sublingual,
de qualquer maneira, você vai acabar
engolindo, né, uma uma parte dessa
progesterona aí e não vai ser totalmente
uma progesterona que não vai ter a
primeira passagem no
fígado. Certo?
Tem uma outra pergunta
aqui, deixa eu ver se é a é é a próxima
que seria a
próxima. Na sua visão, essa associação
entre doenças mentais e crimes de que a
doença em tal
contribui não ser exagero, sendo que uma
pessoa esquizofrênica, ela tenha o seu
caráter e sua índole. E também é difícil
saber se a pessoa agiu baseada na doença
mental ou por livre vontade e se esconde
no transtorno ou no suposto transtorno.
Nos Estados Unidos o doente mental é
mantido preso em células separadas, mas
é mantido preso você corrobora como
médico com o meu ponto de
vista? Bem, eh isso é muito complexo,
tá? Os dados mostram que, embora exista
uma correlação, uma associação
estatística entre esquizofrenia e
criminalidade, ela tende a ser bem menos
dramática do que muita gente percebe.
Teve um estudo australiano que durou 25
anos, ele encontrou que 21% dos
pacientes com
esquizofrenia tiveram condenações
criminais versus 7,8% da população
geral.
Entretanto, quando analisamos apenas
casos sem uso de substâncias, né, no
caso drogas, etc., sem abuso de
substâncias, o risco aumenta apenas
ligeiramente, tá? Então, existe essa
questão do uso de
drogas. Então, a evidência mais robusta
indica que o abuso de substâncias é o
verdadeiro mediador da violência, tá? O
abuso de substâncias contribui para 34%
do risco atribuível.
populacional para violência, enquanto
transtornos mentais maiores contribuem
apenas 4,3%.
em pacientes com esquizofrenia, sem
comorbidade de uso de substâncias, né,
de drogas, o risco de crime violento é
minimamente aumentado. Então, realmente
isso é um dado
interessante. Então, é interessante, até
filosófico essa questão de distinguir
entre ações motivados pela doença e
aquelas que refletem escolhas pessoais.
Isso é uma coisa assim bem difícil às
vezes a gente
concluir. Teve um estudo na Associação
Americana de Psicologia que que
encontrou apenas 7,5% dos crimes
cometidos por pessoas com doença mental
grave foram diretamente relacionados à
doença mental
subjacente. Então o que que
significa? Isso sugere que a maioria dos
crimes não é diretamente causado pelos
sintomas psiquiátricos.
Então, pesquisas sobre livre arbítrio em
pacientes com esquizofrenia mostram que
aqueles com maior senso de livre
arbítrio tendem a ter menos sintomas
psiquiátricos, sugerindo que a percepção
de agência pessoal poderia ser
preservada mesmo na presença de doença
mental.
E vamos falar um pouquinho sobre o
sistema prisional americano. Ele de fato
mantém pessoas com doença mental presas,
frequentemente em condições de
confinamento
solitário. Aproximadamente 28% das
pessoas em confinamento solitário em
prisões de Nova York tem diagnóstico de
saúde mental
reconhecido. E mais de 70% das pessoas
em prisões americanas t pelo menos uma
doença mental diagnosticada ou
transtorno por uso de
substâncias. Então é bem complexo daqui,
né?
Então, aparentemente, a associação entre
doença mental e criminalidade é
frequentemente exagerada ou mal
compreendida. Os fatores
socioeconômicos, demográficos e abusos
substâncias aparentemente são os
principais determinantes da violência.
Bem, vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Aliás, essas foram as seis perguntas
iniciais, mas entraram mais perguntas
hoje. Deixa eu achar as outras
aqui. Me deem só um
instante. OK.
Aqui tem como reverter placas nas
carotas? Tem sim, viu? Tem como
reverter? Eu geralmente uso uma
combinação de natoquinas,
piquinogenol e substâncias que aumentam
o metabolismo do óxido nítrico para
poder fazer isso, tá? Mas os estudos que
eu li sobre isso falam que demoram de 2
a tr anos para acontecer esse processo.
Tem que ter muita determinação, muita
disciplina de tomar com regularidade
diariamente esse protocolo para poder
ter esses resultados.
Tá? Vamos paraa
próxima. Trevo vermelho seria bom para
Parkinson?
Se sim, apenas o chá ou
cápsulas. O trevil vermelho é um
componente do hormona, né? Ele é bom
para questões hormonais. Para
Parkinson nunca vi nada a
respeito. Vou dar uma checada nisso
agora.
Bem, eu nem sabia, tá? Aparentemente
sim. Tem evidências que o trevo vermelho
tem efeito neuroprotetor para Parxon.
Teve estudos que mostraram que extratos
ricos em isoflavonas do trevo vermelho,
né, que é usado, como eu falei, no
hormona, né, que é um produto aí da
manipulação que é para ajudar pessoas na
perimenopausa, de fato, protege
neurônios dopaminésicos, são os
neurônios afetados pela
doença. Isso em estudo de culturas
celulares, tá? Que foram expostas a
toxinas que levaram ao Parxon em modelo
animal. En vitro foi constatado em
modelo animal que seria em
vivo, os extratos de trevo vermelho
reduziram disfunção motora nos ratos,
tá? E a gente sempre prefere em
cápsulas, né, com extrato padronizado em
relação ao
chá, obviamente porque a gente consegue
eh isolar os princípios ativos de
maneira mais eficiente, né?
Eu nunca usei esse
esse princípio para Parkon, mas de fato
ele tem um efeito
sim. Quais são as limitações? A maioria
das evidências vem de modelos celulares,
né, em vitro e animais em vivo. Estudos
em humanos ainda são limitados e não tem
dado sobre eficácia a longo
prazo. E outra coisa, como ele tem ação
hormonal, ele pode interferir com
terapias hormonais. caso esse parxoniano
esteja fazendo
uso. Beleza, vamos ver se tem mais
alguma
perguntinha. Ah, tem mais. O pessoal tá
colocando perguntas
aqui. Tá, tem uma pergunta da pessoa que
fez aquela pergunta enorme. Ele fez uma
pergunta de seguimento aqui, tá?
tá perguntando de enema de café. Sim, o
enema de café ajuda, no caso aí se o seu
fígado não tá funcionando bem por causa
da deficiência
da alfa 1 antase.
Bom, n de café vai
ajudar. E o melhor caminho é você marcar
com geneticista, tá? Por
favor, e dá suporte pro fígado, como eu
já expliquei na quando tava respondendo
a sua pergunta.
Vamos
lá. Fiz um teste chamado G effects. É um
exame sofisticado de função
intestinal pela Genova ou Genova
Diagnostics. No PCR. mostrou algumas
bactérias
desbalanceadas. Porém, na cultura não
apresentou o crescimento de
fungos, o que, pelos sintomas, era o que
eu suspeitava mais. Apenas a cultura
seria o método de diagnóstico confiável?
Não, não é porque a maioria das
bactérias não crescem em meio de
cultura. É por isso que usa
esses mecanismos genéticos do RNA na
bactéria, né? O RNA 16.
Então o a cultura ela
ajuda, mas ela isoladamente não resolve,
precisa fazer junto esse teste genético
das bactérias que eles fazem de
microbioma.
Então, a cultura seria um método de
diagnóstico confiável para determinar
que estou lidando apenas com CBO e não
CFO. E a outros testes para confirmar
esse teste que eu acabei de comentar que
que eles fazem de microbioma que não é
cultura. irei apresentar os resultados
ao meu médico, mas gostaria de saber a
sua
opinião. Então, a questão do, como eu
falei, né, os testes microbioma, eles
vão verificar através do DNA da
bactéria, no caso, no caso, nem é DNA
RNA 16s, as espécies que foram
constatadas. Agora o
fungo, você tem que buscar os
metabólitos fúngicos. Às vezes tem que
fazer exame de cios
urinários para verificar isso daí, tá?
Aí tem que complementar com outro exame
que seros urinários, tá?
O que estraga os dentes faz com que eles
caiam ou apodreçam em uma pessoa, em
algumas pessoas e outras não? Tem várias
questões. É o consumo de açúcar sem uma
higiene
adequada, vai causar bacteriana nesse
dente. Aí esse dente vai eh sendo
corruído aos poucos, aí ele amolece e
cai. E também tem a questão óssea, né?
Às vezes essa pessoa ela pode ter um
problema já de reabsorção óssea por
trauma ou por outras questões e esse
dente perde sustentação e cai, tá?
Então, basicamente infecção crônica com
a higiene ou perda de sustentação óssea,
que é muito mais comum em pessoas
idosas, tá?
Demência no início tem sintomas
semelhantes ao atismo ou esquizofrenia
leve? Não, eu não diria que demência no
início tem sintomas semelhantes à
autismo. Demência no início, a pessoa
vai ter déficit de memória, vai ter uma
memória curta, prejudicada, vai
perguntar a mesma coisa várias
vezes, tá? E isso é diferente do
autismo. O autismo não tem deficiente de
memória. Ela pode ter também défic de
descalculia, não consegue fazer cálculo
matemático da mesma maneira, mas também
não é sintoma de autismo, né? E ela pode
também perder a orientação espacial, que
também não
é sintoma de autismo, tá? Não tem nada a
ver.
esquizofrenia leve seria muito mais um
distudo de personalidade que a pessoa,
na verdade, ela pode ter alucinações
auditivas, alucinações visuais, ela pode
ter signo de
persecultória. Isso também não se
confunde com demência. Aliás, a demência
pode ter sim
alucinações, mas não é geralmente um
sintoma inicial de demência leve, tá?
Então não tem essas confusões não.
Ã, no grupo do WhatsApp, uma pessoa
postou a seguinte resposta, uma
pergunta, por favor, dê sua opinião.
Substituir formina não é algo simples.
Você pode tentar berberina, mas é bem
mais caro. É, ele tem razão nesse ponto.
A beberina é mais cara e o efeito talvez
não seja da mesma intensidade. Sim, só
testando, né? Eles são semelhantes, mas
não tenho garantia de que a biberina vai
substituir a
metiformina. O melhor a fazer, tentar
reduzir o consumo de carboidratos, que
não é fácil. Eu acho que essa frase tá
muito correta, tá
muito eh digamos assim de bom senso,
tá? Temos algumas perguntas ao vivo
aqui. Olá, doutor, boa noite. Tenho 55
anos. Estou com alguns nódulos na
tireoide e um nódulo de 1,4 cm no lado
esquerdo. Resultado da punção Betesda 5.
Resolvi apostar no
protocolo. Qual o protocolo,
Maura? Ah, tá, tá continuando aqui.
Tratamento suporte para nódulos de
tireoide para pessoas com anticorpos
normais. Já estou entrando no terceiro
mês de comprimidos. Achei que o lado
esquerdo da minha tireoide está um pouco
maior. Tratamento de suporte seria
vitaminas e minerais. O que você tá
querendo dizer com
isso? Para quem já teve herpes o hoster,
é contraindicado o uso do pea? Não, não
é, Eliane, pode
usar. Ana Paula aqui tá comentando que o
Cifo e o Sibo são distintos. O cifo é
fungo e cibo é bactéria,
tá? Posso falar agora, tá? Tem um teste
espiratório que é teste de gás espirados
que você consume lactulose e aí você
sopra no aparelho e aí
dependendo do grau de hidrogênio que
você espirar e tem aparelhos também que
medem metano ou sulfeto de hidrogênio, a
gente consegue ver se a pessoa tá com
proliferação bacteriana num delgado, que
é o cibo, tá?
Então existe esses três tipos de cibo
através do tipo de gás que é emitido,
né? Se hidrogênio, sufeito de
hidrogênio, sem metano. Já o sifo é
fungo, não tem como ver através desse
teste, tá? Porque ele só pega
bactéria. Olá, Alice Vogel, tudo
bem? Como saber se uma pessoa com
diabetes pode reverter o diabetes com
dieta cetogênica?
Na verdade, só testando, né? Você pode
fazer o
teste, aplica a dieta e verifica. Se a
diabetes for muito longa, de muito tempo
de duração, pode acontecer do diabetes
não reverter por falência da parte
endócrina do
pâncreas. Qual o exame e o número dos
exames? Não
entendi. De nada. Boa
noite. Bem, eu não respondi a Maura
porque não ficou muito claro o que que
ela
queria. Ela falou no tratamento de
suporte, que não sei bem o que ela tá
falando, se é vitamina, se é mineral, se
é nutrexona, se é o que que é. E ela diz
que o lado esquerdo da tireoide está um
pouco maior. Você está ao vivo, Maura?
O meu protocolo, você fala do documento
lá. É
isso bem. Se se é o do documentos é
vitaminas e minerais,
né?
Entendi. E se é normal um lado esquerdo
tá maior que o outro? Não, não é normal.
É melhor você fazer outrassom, tá? Para
ver o que tá acontecendo. Pode ser que
esteja fazendo uma tiroidite, tá bom?
Bem, eu tinha separado umas coisas pra
gente conversar aqui fora as perguntas,
né? Então, tem algumas novidades sobre a
vitamina D.
Bem, vamos falar aqui sobre algumas
novidades no mundo da vitamina
D, especialmente relacionado à saúde
intestinal.
Então, pesquisas mais recentes estão
revelando que a vitamina D, já sabíamos
disso, mas a medicina mais ortodoxa tá
aceitando agora, então ela teria um
papel fundamental na saúde intestinal.
Então, ela tem sim, a gente já sabe
alguns anos que a vitamina D tem um
papel na questão do liquigat. Então, a
vitamina D previne o intestino
hiperpermeável e ajuda a fortalecer as
junções das células intestinais, né? as
tight junctions que a gente fala
aqui. Então, finalmente a medicina
ortodoxa tá começando a dar o devido
valor à vitamina D, que não é só questão
de osso, né? não é só questão de evitar
osteomalácia ou
osteoporose. Então, uma descoberta muito
interessante. Pescadores de Harvard
acabaram de publicar um estudo mostrando
que a vitamina D pode desacelerar o
envelhecimento biológico. Então, eles
descobriram que pessoas que tomavam
suplementos de vitamina D tm telômeros
mais longos, né? Então, para quem não
sabe, telômeros são aquelas pontinhas
dos cromossomos que parece muito com
aquela pontinha de plástico que tem, por
exemplo, nos cadaços de tênis, tá? São
pontas de proteção pros cromossomos,
como é o equivalente daquela pontinha de
plástico no cadastro do tênis. Então,
quanto mais curto essa pontinha de
proteção, mais envelhecidos nós estamos.
Então, a vitamina D consegue prevenir o
equivalente a quase 3 anos de
envelhecimento, tá? Então, isso é um
estudo que saiu recentemente, que é
muito interessante. Vale muito a pena a
gente manter a vitamina D na faixa aí de
50 a
70. Em relação ao intestino,
né, temos dados novos aí.
Quando nós tomamos sol ou quando a gente
ingere a vitamina
D, ela vai pro fígado e depois pros
rins. E no rim ela é transformada na
forma mais
ativa. E no no intestino, a vitamina D
se liga a receptores especiais na célula
de
defesa. Então a vitamina D funciona como
a chave mestra que abre várias portas
importantes no nosso intestino. Ela
regula inflamação, ela protege a
barreira intestinal, ela influencia as
bactérias boas que vivem no
intestino. E estudos recentes mostram
que quando suplementamos ela melhora
significativamente a diversidade das
bactérias benéficas, tá? Essa é outra
novidade. Então, a vitamina D, além de
melhorar as type junctions, ela ajuda a
melhorar a diversidade
bacteriana e ela aumenta especificamente
as bactérias que aumentam o butirato, o
produzem butirato ou ácido butírico, que
é um um ácido gráxo cadeia curta que
protege nosso intestino, reduz
inflamação e ajuda a prevenir câncer de
intestino grosso, tá? Então, olha só a
importância da vitamina D intestinal.
Então, temos dados específicos para
algumas doenças, tá? Vamos falar da
diverticulose, que é responsável pela
diverticulite e só diverticulite causa
mais de 200.000 hospitalizações por ano
nos Estados
Unidos. Pessoas com níveis adequados de
vitamina D tem um
riscofativamente menor desenvolver a
diverticulite, né?
Em relação à retocolite oativa e a
doença de crom, a vitamina D também
previne a deficiência dessa vitamina
afeta cerca de 45% dos pacientes que tm
retocolite e pode chegar a 100% em
alguns grupos com doença de crom.
E a deficiência não é apenas
consequência da doença, ela também pode
contribuir pro desenvolvimento e pior
das
condições. Então, estudos mostram que a
suplementação com vitamina D em
pacientes com essas doenças melhora a
composição da microbiota intestinal e
reduz inflamação. E tem também estudo
sobre câncer de intestino grosso. Um
estudo húngaro que foi publicado esse
ano, analisou mais de 1,3 milhão de
pessoas e descobriu que a vitamina D tem
um papel crítico na prevenção e no
tratamento do câncer intestino grosso.
Então, níveis baixos de vitamina D
aumentam o risco de desenvolver câncer
de intestino grosso, o colorretal e pior
um prognóstico quando a doença já está
presente. Então, precisa repor a
vitamina D nesses casos, tanto para
prevenir quanto para tratar.
e níveis adequados de vitamina D tem um
efeito protetor impressionante, ajudando
no reparo do DNA através das proteínas
especiais chamad
cirtuínas. Tem mais informações ainda,
mais novidades. Pesquisadores alemães
descobriram que tomar vitamina D
diariamente pode reduzir a mortalidade
pro câncer em 12% de modo geral.
E em pessoas com peso normal, a vitamina
D reduziu em 38% o risco de câncer com
metástase ou
fatal. Também tem um estudo vital que
foi feito em Harvard com mais de 25.000
participantes e que mostrou que a
suplementação com a vitamina D reduziu
em 22% o risco de desenvolver do
autoimunes como artrite, hematoide,
tiroidite, rachimoto e
psoríase. Pessoas que tm fígado
gorduroso, né,
esteatose tem frequentemente deficiência
de vitamina D e a suplementação pode
ajudar a reduzir fibrose e o acúmulo de
gordura no
fígado. E também aquela história que nós
falamos durante a pandemia, que foi
muito negada na
época, estudos comprovam que pessoas com
deficiente de vitamina D tinham 77% mais
chances para testar positivo para
C19 e a suplementação com vitamina
D reduziu simativamente o risco de
internação e o TI. Isso foi falado muito
naquela época, há três anos atrás. Eu
falei muito disso, agora estou
reconhecendo. Então, a suplementação com
vitamina D reduziu de maneira
significativa o risco de internação em
UTI e a
mortalidade. Em relação à síndrome
metabólica, pessoas com níveis adequados
de vitamina D tem aproximadamente metade
do risco de desenvolver cinometabólica
comparada àquelas que têm deficiência
severa. Então isso quer dizer o quê?
menos risco de diabetes, pressão alta e
alterações de
colesterol. E tem alguns estudos que
estão mostrando também que tomar
vitamina D todos os dias é mais eficaz
do que
reduzir do que tomar em doses mais altas
espaçadas, tá? Então, se você puder
tomar todo dia, em vez de tomar doses
altas espaçadas, é
melhor. Então, essa é a informação que
eu queria passar para vocês da vitamina
D. Posso tomar na 600 mg por dia também
para tireoide? Pode, pode sim.
Bem,
pessoal, eu acho que era isso por hoje,
né? Já respondi todas as
perguntas e eu preciso ajudar a D. Ana
Paula aí que chegou aí com as malas da
outra clínica. Tá bom? Agradeço muito a
vocês aí pela participação e a gente se
vê na semana que vem. Um abraço.